Leo está en la búsqueda
de huevos de pascua
en su patio don su patio
donde sus padres
escondieron huevos de plástico,
lo cuales contienen una moneda
de 25 centavos o de 10 centavos,
en cada uno de los huevos
va a encontrar una moneda,
ya sea de 25 centavos
o en su dado caso de 10 centavos.
Cuando ha encontrado
todos los huevos...
ya encontró todos
los huevos escondidos en su jardín...
cuenta su botín y descubre que tiene
4 pesos con 80 centavos.
Escribe la ecuación para representar
el número de monedas
de 25 centavos,
con la letra "q"
y de 10 centavos,
con la letra "d"
que Leo  ha embolsado.
Ok, pues bueno, vamos a escribir aquí la
ecuación que nos piden.
Y para esto, quiero que te des cuenta que
él junto en total,
4 pesos con 80 centavos,
contando con esto la cantidad de monedas
de 25 centavos que él tiene
y contando la cantidad de monedas
de 10 centavos que él tiene.
Y entonces, utilizando esta información
vamos a sacar la primera ecuación
y esta ecuación
la voy a escribir de la siguiente manera,
primero vamos a fijarnos en "q",
recuerda que "q" es la cantidad
de monedas de 25 centavos
que ha encontrado Leo,
ahora,
como cada una de estas monedas
tiene un valor de 25 centavos,
entonces voy a escribir aquí 0.25,
0.25 por "q",
esto me está representando
la cantidad
de dinero que va a obtener Leo
con las monedas de 25 centavos,
por ejemplo,
si tuviera dos monedas
de 25 centavos,
entonces él tendría
50 centavos, ok,
pero a esto hay que agregarle,
a esto le voy a sumar...
y para esto le voy a sumar aquí...
la cantidad de monedas que se encontró él
de 10 centavos que es "d",
pero también lo voy a multiplicar
por su valor, su valor es 0.10,
porque son 10 centavos
lo que vale cada una de ellas...
éste no es un 0, perfecto...
0.10 por "d"
y lo estoy poniendo multiplicando a la cantidad
de monedas de 10 centavos para que me dé
la cantidad total de dinero que
voy a obtener de las monedas de 10 centavos.
Por ejemplo, si Leo se encontró 3 monedas
de 10 centavos, entonces aquí tendría
30 centavos con estas 3 monedas.
Pero, lo yo sé es que es la cantidad de dinero
que me dé las monedas de 25 centavos,
más la cantidad de dinero
que me dé las monedas de 10 centavos,
esto tiene que ser exactamente
igual a una cierta cantidad,
a lo que se encontró él en total,
lo cual es
4 pesos con 80 centavos,
por lo tanto voy a escribir aquí 4.80,
porque es la cantidad de dinero que se encontró
en total Leo.
Ok, ya tengo la ecuación y dice
"0.25q" más "0.10d"
esto es igual a 4.80.
Ahora, vamos a ver qué me dice
en la frase de aquí abajo.
Si Leo ha encontrado 36 huevos, ok,
en total encontró 36 huevos
y bueno, recuerda que
cada uno de los huevos tiene una moneda,
ya sea de 25 centavos
o de 10 centavos.
¿Cuántos de ellos
contienen monedas de 25 centavos?
¡De lujo! y esto me está dando pie
a pensar en otra ecuación,
así que para esto voy a sacar aquí
mi libreta de apuntes
o mi pizarrón electrónico para que
así podamos trabajar
la siguiente ecuación.
Ya habíamos obtenido la primera ecuación,
la cual decía que 0,
que 0.25, ok,
esto que multiplica a "q", ok,
hablando de las monedas de 25 centavos
y bueno, aquí tengo representado
la cantidad de dinero
que me dan las monedas
de 10 centavos,
ok, si a esto le agregáramos...
si a esto le agregamos
0.10
por "d"
que era la cantidad de monedas
de 10 centavos que nosotros teníamos
y bueno, aquí, justo aquí,
tenemos representada la cantidad de dinero
que nos van a dar las monedas de 10 centavos,
entonces la suma de estos dos
me tenían que dar 4.80...
4.80...
4 pesos con 80 centavos,
ok, de lujo.
Aquí ya tenemos una ecuación la cual representa
la cantidad de dinero total
que obtuvimos de estas monedas
de 25 centavos y de 10 centavos.
Ahora, vamos a fijarnos
qué es lo que dice aquí abajo.
Leo ha encontrado 36 huevos,
eso nos da pie a pensar en otra ecuación,
¿qué otra ecuación?
Bueno, la ecuación que
va a decir que "q"...
que "q" más "d"...
"q" más "d"...
déjame cambiar al color de "d",
que era justo éste...
esto tiene que
ser exactamente igual a 36,
¿y cómo puedo obtener esta ecuación?
Bueno, pues es que date cuenta
que tenemos solamente 36 huevos
y cada uno de esos huevos
tiene o una moneda de 25 centavos
o una moneda de 10 centavos,
por cada huevo hay una moneda.
Por lo tanto, tenemos 36 monedas,
36 moneda de las cuales algunas
son de 25 centavos
y otras de 10 centavos.
Ahora, como nosotros sabemos
hay varios métodos
para resolver este tipo
de sistemas de ecuaciones,
porque date cuenta,
tenemos dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas,
dos ecuaciones lineales.
Y bueno, tenemos por ejemplo,
el método de sustitución
o bueno, también tenemos el
método de suma y restas,
si nosotros escalamos
una de esas dos ecuaciones multiplicándola
por una constante
para que se puedan eliminar
o bueno, hay muchos métodos más pero en
esta ocasión quiere ver
el método de sustitución.
Por el método de sustitución
vamos a resolver este problema,
así que de esta ecuación,
de la ecuación de aquí abajo
déjame despejar a "q".
Y bueno, si yo resto "d" de ambos lados de
esta ecuación, voy a obtener que "q",
"q" es exactamente lo mismo que 36...
que 36 a esto le voy a quitar "d",
de lujo.
Y entonces si sustituyo
a "q" en esta ecuación,
ya voy a encontrar una ecuación
que solamente depende de "d"
y de hecho, me va a quedar
lo siguiente, me va a quedar,
0.25
que multiplica a "q",
¡oh!, pero nosotros sabemos
que "q" vale 36 menos "d",
entonces voy a sustituir
el valor de "q" justo aquí
y entonces me va a quedar,
0.25 que multiplica
a 36...
a 36 menos...
menos "d", ok,
36 menos "d"
y a esto le sumamos, "0.10d"
esto tiene que ser igual a 4.80...
déjame ponerlo con su respectivo color...
a 4.80, ok.
Y date cuenta que con esto
vamos a obtener el valor de "d"
y después vamos a obtener
el valor de las monedas de 25 centavos...
Bueno... bueno, tal vez una manera más directa,
tú podrías obtener este valor que nosotros buscamos,
el de las monedas de 25 centavos,
si de esta ecuación hubiésemos despejado a "d",
pero bueno, ya despejamos a "q"
y entonces vamos a trabajar
con esta ecuación de aquí,
¿y qué me va a quedar?
Bueno, pues tengo 0.25 por 36,
bueno, esto es lo mismo que 36 por 1/4
ó dividir 36 entre 4, l
o cual es lo mismo que 9...
9 menos 0.25 por "d",
lo cual es "0.25d"...
0.25 ok,
esto que multiplica a "d", ok,
y a esto le voy a sumar...
a esto le voy a sumar,
"0.10d", ok,
y esto tiene que ser igual a 4.80...
a 4.80...
a 4.80.
Ahora, lo que quiero es obtener
el valor de "d" positivo,
por lo tanto
voy a pasar este
"0.25d" del otro lado,
este "10d" del otro lado
y este 4.80
lo voy a pasar de este lado,
de tal manera que me va
a quedar lo siguiente.
Aquí voy a, éste es menos,
aquí voy a sumar
"0.25d", ok,
aquí voy a restar...
voy a restar "0.10d", ok,
y de este lado derecho de la ecuación,
lo que voy a hacer es,
primero sumar,
voy a sumar "0.25d", ok,
y a esto le voy a restar "0.10d",
lo que haga de un lado
lo voy a hacer exactamente igual del otro,
ok.
Y ahora,
este 4.80 lo voy a pasar de este lado
y lo voy a pasar de este lado
con signo contrario,
de tal manera que de este lado
me va a quedar
-4.8
y de este lado también,
-4.8,
ok, de tal manera que ahora sí,
estos dos se van a cancelar,
estos dos se van a cancelar
y del lado izquierdo
solamente me va a quedar,
9,
9 menos 4.8,
lo cual es lo
mismo que 4.2,
aquí me queda 4.2,
esto es exactamente igual que...
y bueno, de este lado estos dos
se van a cancelar,
ok, y estos se pueden reducir,
"0.25d" menos "0.10d"
esto es lo mismo que,
"0.15d", ok, de lujo.
Pero esto,  esto me va a implicar
una operación que tenga que ver con decimales,
así que lo mejor
es pasar esto a fracciones,
se me ocurre pasar el 0.15 a fracción
y bueno, 0.15, nosotros sabemos
que es lo mismo que 15 sobre 100,
ok, y a esto le puedo sacar quinta,
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 3 entre 20...
3 entre 20,
si yo le saco quinta y entonces
esta expresión de aquí me va a quedar de
la siguiente manera,
esto es lo mismo que
sobre 20 que multiplica a "d",
esto es igual a 4.2,
pero 4.2 también lo voy a escribir
como una fracción.
4.2...
4.2
es lo mismo que 42/10, ok,
y esto es lo mismo que si saco mitad arriba
y mitad abajo,
me queda 21 sobre 5,
ok, lo voy a escribir
así 21/5.
Ok, entonces llego a esta ecuación de aquí,
que la voy a escribir justo acá abajo,
esto es lo mismo que 3 sobre 20,
que multiplica a "d",
esto es igual a 21 entre 5...
a 21 entre 5,
pero como quiero obtener el valor de "d",
entonces voy a multiplicar por el recíproco,
es decir, voy a multiplicar
aquí por 20 entre 3
y aquí voy a multiplicar por 20 entre 3,
ok,
vamos a multiplicar de tal manera
que estos se van,
éste y éste, éste y éste, se van,
y solamente
me queda que "d",
"d" es igual a 21 entre 3...
21 entre 3,
lo cual es 7,
si reduzco éste con éste me queda 7
y aquí lo voy a multiplicar
por 20 entre 5,
20 entre 5 es lo mismo que 4,
7 por 4 es 28, ok, de lujo.
La cantidad de monedas
de 10 centavos eran 28,
pero yo lo que quiero saber es
la cantidad de monedas de 25 centavos,
por lo tanto, yo sé que "q"
es igual a 36 menos "d",
o dicho de otra manera,
para obtener el valor de "q"
lo que tengo que hacer
es tomarme 36 menos 28...
lo voy a poner así...
36 menos 28
y entonces me va a dar que
36 menos 28 es 8.
"q" es igual a 8,
tenemos 8 monedas
de 25 centavos.
Y por lo tanto,
vamos a escribirlo justo aquí, en mi opción.
8,
8 es la cantidad de monedas
que tengo de 25 centavos
y de lujo, estamos bien.